ah Brazil the beautiful sunkissed home
of Pele hairless genitalia and the
world's largest Jared Leto statue to
show my dedication to the legions of
Brazilian Deadpool fans
I've spent up to 20 minutes on Google
Translate as well as countless hours
watching telenovelas to teach me
everything about your official language
that's right but I see you this sexy red
spandex task learn to speak Portuguese
all right
hopefully I get the accent right here
goes the second a co-sponsor presenter
on our sson heritage SEO nuna comic-con
Brazil voman Darmstadt Oh odorous mas o
menos de knowledge preserve sakoku
nukemama Bella Terra Bella as a guru she
assented a leash Vogons are pelo Co Co
Co Co Masha Kiran comics LG fridge
orange ml Apache cave I say
completamente gratis innovate Costa nada
assassin Aaron contrato Dispenza
se prepara regard Rai Bachchan new Baku
mahjong Falacci opsins porque Hamada
season 5 cocoon gossip resembling a mo
kamo Mo Kio temple ami emoji data hidden
samba pelon
Familia specific Comanche swamp mine
Karen elephant poo taka Fatima ha ha
Gullu Peloso pi ish it's my opportunity
spoke to some modellers Prez own suggest
Oprah made a vase or Chima I want for
say I'm a Sookie be don't tap another
Enya you just cause I'm Angelica look me
straight in the nipples and tell me I
didn't just nail that now what are you
waiting for go to the website below to
reserve your spot and you're sure to be
the talk of southbound though space is
limited so best hurry because I think we
can all agree there's nothing like a
wild day or night in Brazil to make a
special memory that you'll cherish
forever
just ask the 2016 US men's swimming team
they'll probably make some [ __ ] up
Jojo
you
you